we're back with our mom's time out our
first one ever
with jana whose story went viral after
posting this pic
of her son ezra very frustrated on his
first day
of virtual kindergarten it's
heartbreaking we all related it went
viral and
you know we're just talking about being
moms and you're trying to do it all
and doing your best and holding your
families together
during these times and i hope that
anyone out there who may be watching
you know who's going through this too
can just join in on this conversation
because we're all trying to
juggle all of this how are you doing
that for sure
how are you doing it uh you know
ironically my kids give me my strength
they're my why they're my reason and
they're my whole world even though
motherhood is like the hardest journey
ever like you said i wouldn't have it
any other way
so i think we're just taking one day at
a time and some days that
you uh are doing great and other days
it's a challenge but you just have to
take it day by day and give yourself a
lot of grace
you said that really your kids
while being the thing that sort of has
to you know you have to give the most
life force to and output wise
is the thing that gives you the strength
in order to do it and again i'm just
like that's what i'm talking about
janna you say things in this way that
just make a relatable light bulb go off
thank you i think like you said all moms
can relate to that that there are why
there are driving force well i think
that you've done
a tremendous thing for people because we
feel better when we know we're all in
the boat together
rather than like in lonely little canoes
you know disconnected and i thought
yours was so selfless and relatable
and this is sort of to me like the
example of how
powerful sharing can be thank you so
much that means a lot and that was the
whole reason behind
sharing this photo was i knew that like
i said
all along that i'm not going to be the
only one
going through this but seeing someone
else post it and
whether that's myself it just resonates
with so many families and that we just
don't want to feel alone in all of this
because it can be a lonely time
may i ask what you said to ezra when you
did see him crying
you took the picture but then what was
your
what was your follow through may i ask
what's your advice
so i asked him to step away from the
computer and he came over by me and we
actually sat on the floor and just
hugged and we both had tears but i told
him that
it's not just hard for him it's hard for
everybody that we're gonna get through
this together
and that we're gonna just try our best
but it was still really hard for him to
understand that this was his reality
that it's going to be on the computer
because even the night before he was
sticking his shoes out for the next day
i love that you said like let's step
away and take a break
i think kids and adults can really
benefit from that kind of
separation it changes and shifts our
energy
i mean you're such a good mom jana what
do you do to take care of yourself what
do you do
how do you how do you you know i know we
all put our kids first but
do you get to do things for yourself
you're such a good mom
thank you so having four kids obviously
that leaves a lot less time for myself
but before kids i was a competitive
figure skater
and then turned coach so that was a huge
part of my life
and now where we live it's the rink is
an hour away
with a land of traffic it's even more
than that so it's not reality for me
right now but i hope to spark that
passion back in my life sometime
oh gosh yeah i think that would be an
amazing prescription
of getting back to also physical
exertion
is so positive for the mental state and
the physical state for taking on all
that you do as a mom
god i want to get you back and find time
for you to figure skate
that would be amazing it's a huge hole
in my heart right now but that's all
right because
there'll be time for it yeah well we uh
have a mom's timeout surprise called um
the polyglide synthetic ice company
is um gonna put a rink in your backyard
i'm like in shock right now uh-huh
apparently they just put one in justin
bieber's backyard so
they know what they're doing wow
yeah and i can't thank thank you
that's amazing you deserve this and i
wish that we could all wave a magic wand
for one another
and we were all so excited and cheering
and freaking out
that we my kids are gonna freak out i
know they can use it too
but this one's all about you janna you
really deserve this
thank you for making us all feel less
alone more connected
and relate to each other i think your
approach and your advice and your
tactics are fantastic
and would it be okay if we once we build
the skate rink
in your backyard we can come visit and
like check it out and see how it's going
for you
um please that would be amazing okay
all right well you give us all strength
and we'll be checking back in
on how the progress is going on your
brand
new ice skating rink in your backyard
[Applause]
well thank you jana so much
[Music]
you